isn't the truth that what has happened  recently and a bit beyond that has  damaged that reputation that it's taken  a hit and that actually your reputation  for economic competence is in tatters at  the moment I think that's overstating it  but I I do accept uh that you know we've  had a rocky period in the last couple of  months I wish that we hadn't had what  happened with the mini budget and all  the turbulence that happened there I  hope  British people who you know won't have  liked seeing their taxes go up will have  been worried about some of the cuts in  the growth in public spending I hope  they understand the purpose of this  wasn't just uh misery for misery's sake  it was to make sure that we really have  that bright future that everyone wants